THE WAY AROUND ON THIS.
WHO IS THIS FOR CHAN PERSON
PERSON OR WEBSITE?
>> I'M SURE WE'RE GOING TO BE
ABLE TO GET MORE CONFIRMATION ON
THIS AS THE HOURS AND MINUTES GO
ON.
HE MAY HAVE BEEN JUST A SYSTEM
ADMINISTRATOR WHO KNEW HIS WAY
AROUND AND HOW TO HACK THINGS.
IT SEEMS LIKE THIS WAS NOT A
REAL BIG EFFORT BUT WAS MORE OF
A I HAVE THESE USERS NAMES AND
KNOW THIS SECURITY LOOPHOLE.
I'M JUST GOING TO RUN THIS
PASSWORD APP AND SEE IF I CAN
GET INTO THESE PEOPLE'S
CLOUD-BASED ACCOUNT.
WHAT'S SAD ABOUT IT, I'M SORRY
THAT I'M LAUGHING BECAUSE IT'S
NOT FUNNY.
IT'S AWFUL IF THIS HAPPENED TO
YOU.
THIS HAS BECOME OUR NEW REALITY
AS WITH THE CLOUD.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WANTED TO GET
TO.
LISTEN, WE'VE ALL, A LOT OF
PEOPLE HAVE.
>> WE'VE ALL DONE THESE THINGS
IN FRONT OF CAMERAS.
>> WHATEVER YOUR SITUATION IS
TAKING A PHOTOGRAPH AND POOF
IT'S OUT THERE IN THE ETHER.
WHAT CAN WE DO TO NOT HAVE THIS
KIND OF STUFF HAPPEN?
>> THERE'S NOT A LOT YOU CAN DO.
WELL, YOU ABSOLUTELY HAVE TO
HAVE GOOD PASSWORDS.
YOU HAVE TO HAVE PASSWORDS THAT
AREN'T WORDS.
LIKE IF YOUR PASSWORD WAS
PASSWORD WHICH IS THE MOST
COMMON PASSWORD, CHANGE THE S TO
A DOLLAR SIGN.
BECAUSE IT'S LOOKING LIKE THIS
GUY WHO GOT IN RAN A PROGRAM
THAT JUST RUNS THROUGH EVERY
WORD IN THE DICTIONARY AND ONE
OF THOSE ENDS UP BEING YOUR
PASSWORD.
THAT'S BAD IF THAT WAS THAT
EASY.
YOU HAVE TO CHANGE YOUR
PASSWORDS AND CONSIDER USING
INENCRYPTION IF YOU'RE BACKING
UP FILES BECAUSE THIS IS COULD
HAPPEN TO YOU IF YOU'RE USING AN
ONLINE BACKUP SERVICE THAT BACKS
UP ALL YOUR COMPUTER.
YOU MIGHT DELETE SOMETHING ON
YOUR LAPTOP BUT IT'S STILL IN
YOUR BACKUP BECAUSE YOU WANT IT
TO BE BECAUSE THAT'S WHY YOU
HAVE A BACK WHY UP.
>> PICTURES HAD BEEN DELETED BUT
THEY WERE STILL FLOATING ON THE
ETHER.
WE LOVE THAT WHEN WE WISH WE HAD
FILES AND WANT TO RECOVER THEM.
>> IF YOUR COMPUTER GETS STOLEN,
YOU THINK THANK GOSH I HAVE ALL
OF MY FILES BACKED UP SO I'M NOT
GOING TO LOSE ANYTHING.
YOU ALSO HAVE FILES BACKED UP
YOU MAY WANT TO PURGE FROM YOUR.
>> PRIVACY ALL THE WAY AROUND
INTO IT WILL BE INTERESTING TO
SEE IF THEY GET PROSECUTED.
>> IT'S A WHOLE LEGAL ANGLE OF
THE STORY.
>> THAT'S GOING